good morning Hank it's Tuesday as you
can see I have not gotten the wall down
yet but I have tried to make the best of
a bad situation you know by sprucing
things up a little Oh new nerdfighters
don't get these jokes and old
nerdfighters wonder why I'm still
singing when I said I wouldn't do that
anymore sorry Hank today's video comes
to you in two very special parts part 1
willies secret shame so Hank Willie and
I have had this longtime agreement that
I would not share his secret shame with
you in the nerdfighters and in exchange
he would not eat the things I love the
most he initially violated this deal by
eating two legs and part of the face off
of the great white wall of cow which by
the way is a reference to my new book
Paper Towns coming out September 22nd in
paperback but I'm getting ahead of
myself that's part two so after the
whole cow Fiasco I sat down with Willie
and I said listen Willie if you eat one
more thing I love that's it I'm sharing
your secret shame and then yesterday I
came home after an errand to find this a
mauled armless figurine of the wookie
who should be our nation's next
president displaying the kind of irony
that one does not generally associate
with West Highland Terriers Willie
chewed chewy that's right Hank Willie
refused to let the Wookiee win and
instead left behind a foot that will
probably require amputation and so now I
am honorbound to reveal Willie's secret
shame
Willie was born with an extra tailbone
that instead of going straight goes down
which means that no matter how hard he
tries my beloved puppy can never achieve
a full tail rection it's always a little
limp at the end part two paper downs
paper back so Hank I'm working on this
new book and whenever I'm writing
something new I can never think about
anything except for the thing I'm
writing but it has come to my attention
that the paperback of Paper Towns comes
out in two weeks so if you haven't had
the chance to read the book and you'd
like to I hope that you'll pick it up
when it comes out on September 22nd or
you could just pre-order it in the
sidebar right now so because I'm super
excited about the release of the Paper
Towns paperback I will be giving away
one copy of the book every day for the
next fourteen days to my favorite ten
word comment at YouTube or at the Ning
it doesn't have to be a 10 word well cat
review of Paper Towns although that
might be a good strategy and then I will
read all the comments in a special video
oh and my favorite out of all the
comments will win this this is something
called a play away it's like an iPod
except instead of containing like all
your favorite songs it contains only the
audiobook of Paper Towns oh and a lot of
you have been asking me about the Paper
Towns movie the movie rights as most of
you know were acquired by mr. Mudd and
mandate the people who made the movie
Juno I wrote the first draft of the
screenplay and now I'm getting started
on the first big revision so I'm going
to be doing that when I'm not working on
my new book so yeah be patient but
hopefully I'll have more of an update
soon thanks to everyone who's read Paper
Towns in English or Dutch or Italian or
whatever or listen to it on audio the
books never feel finished until you read
them so thanks for making it feel done
so that I could start a new one Hank
I'll see you singing tomorrow I caught
that dftba
the way I said I caught that implied
that it was the first time I tried which
it wasn't the previous time I hid my own
face Hank oh that hurt